[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy sunday we're going to deliver like
alvin kamara on your fantasy team
welcome to the squad ride presented by
draftkings
live from the bleacher report app my
name is cabbie richards
in the middle she is our betting expert
and wonder woman
that is kelly stewart and a man who's
not afraid to dance on anybody's logo
that is greg ivory kelly before we start
on christmas day your favorite head
coach
mike zimmer said this and i'm quoting br
gridiron
this is a bad defense worst i've ever
had did he keep it 100 or was he being a
grinch
no you're right cabbie i mean look when
alva camaro gets to just
run all over your defense that's a
problem as a former defensive
coordinator i expect
better from one of my favorite coaches i
mean let's just be honest me and coach
zimmer really had a falling out this
year
over the spread like he had in years
past it's just sometimes it's time to
move on from those toxic
well relationships defense gave up seven
touchdowns and this is a show where we
bet on anytime touchdowns and if you've
been riding with us
you've been doing very well salute to
jonathan taylor who cashed a touchdown
for us
last week thank you sir and also great
pick by noah barelli
we are 11 and 4 on the squad ride baby
on friday we asked you on social to drop
your pick to score a touchdown this week
and the fellas
have been putting up consistent numbers
all season let's check the board to see
who we got these are your favorite picks
for week 16. i like that david
montgomery is up there he had a career
146 on the on the ground last week
travis kelsey number two
receiver in the nfl for now that guy's
been super consistent listen
last week was as shocking for us as it
was for you the
jets won a game on the road hit me with
the greg
the jet and our audience is leaning on
some old favorites to get us through
week 16.
what up you are betting about to get
ready for this weekend anytime touchdown
scores this week
lamar jackson lock it in boys
jonathan taylor lock
travis kelsey here let's see who's
scoring a touchdown this week aubry
come on tyree kill
i've been compiling code for three hours
now
we got it is that the broncos helmet
melvin gordon
anytime touch on score let's get it
we got washington football team based in
a nine win seahawks
half is scary you know who else is scary
scary terry
six points touchdown
creativity's off hey cavi that's it
that's your buddy
hey that just put me in the mood i was
in the comments
while i was uh watching the video and
and in the comments bro they're so funny
i got handy dandy ipod greg you
can you flash your handy-dandy ipad like
my name
shouts out to you for getting creative
handy dandy ipad
you are walking away with a hoodie
cabbie i'm in the comments
not that not gary is garland says i'm a
place send me a hoodie
ah i don't know about that i'm that's
not deserving for
of a hoodie i got one more this is this
is to you
they added you cabbie richards squad
ride has been goaded thanks to you guys
leaning on king henry to put on the show
vargas bargastas
i'm sorry if i butchered that but the
producers will get that vargas this
you're walking away with hoodie you're
showing my guy cabbie love
appreciate uh cabbie appreciate it i'm
done man
let's get this show on the road let's
get this show on the road
out of here let's go i think maybe it's
b augustus but i saw that
that king henry jiff and it was sick we
have five legendary videos to show you
and one of those will be our squad ride
so let the tournament begin our first
pitch
comes from casey mint 40 the wheel
legend
all right i've done it this way before
and it always works is there any time
touch to unlock
johnny taylor up from wisconsin
i need to get that program on my
computer will help me out a lot with my
wagers well done wheel legend our next
pitch comes from
the christmas tree legend hunter parsons
fan page
you guys thought like to show off my
tree a little bit um
my parents said they put some new
ornaments on it i'm not really sure what
all new they have on it but uh
here it is i mean it looks pretty nice
what the heck is this uh lamar jackson
anytime touchdown score
i guess that's what we're going with
this weekend all right
nice work jonathan taylor versus lamar
jackson
g-money what'd you think of those videos
cabbie uh the wheel legend i mean i i
also
want to know what program that is
because there's been times where i just
needed to you know spin the wheel to
determine what bet i'm riding with i'm
rocking with that shouts out to willow
fortune also because that that reminded
me of that
jonathan taylor though the pick sitting
at plus money cabbie
i i actually like this let me tell you
why jonathan
taylor he he scored three touchdowns in
his last two games
cabbie and and he he won it for us last
week so
you know he he's got the hot hand uh i'm
liking the plus money right there but
let's talk about the other pick let's
talk about the christmas tree legend now
i don't know about you but i like my
locks at the top of the tree my guy had
to lock like
closer to the bottom you know you know
what i mean maybe the dog can reach it
or something no no no no
i need my locks at the top of the tree
but shouts out to the pick lamar jackson
plus 120 lamar ball last week kelly
lamar bald against that jaguars defense
they're facing the giants today
uh he had four he has four touchdowns in
his last three games i mean lamar
sitting at plus money i like it kelly
now talk to me
lamar jackson jonathan taylor
it's a tough one talk to me kelly you're
right i wanted lamar jackson last week
instead of
jonathan taylor but guess what jonathan
taylor proved me wrong he scored a
touchdown like right
out of the gate so he got us an easy
cash when we didn't have to sweat so
shout out to him
look this is tough because uh i know i
was on the steelers two weeks ago as my
best bet
and got absolutely railroaded i said i
didn't have the guts to bet the bengals
on monday night i did have the over
we got there i like the steelers this
week i i put them when they were plus
one and a half and a teaser
i played them plus one and a half i know
that right now they're a pick em minus
one over at draftkings i gotta check my
phone to double check that
but man this is tough i don't want to
get involved in that game at this point
in time any further than i already have
on the flip side you got lamar jackson
against a giants team that he should be
able to beat at home he should be able
to run all over
what it doesn't matter whether it's colt
mccoy or danny dimes they're both the
same on the same playing field
they both make mistakes and just are
very lackluster
i know that they were able to shut down
russell wilson
at seattle but i would be very very
surprised if they're able to get the win
over the ravens i lean jackson here but
i really don't think he could go wrong
with either pick
well i mean kelly's leaning jackson let
me get into the comments because i have
my handy dandy ipad right here
handy dandy ipad right here there's
lamar right as you can see
exactly kelly you can see lamar is in
the comments chris amiano
that's not deserving of a hoodie not yet
but chris amiano is in the comments
i'm in the comments uh i'm seeing lamar
big mike 13 lamar's gonna light it up in
the end zone
like a christmas tree big mike you're
walking away with a hoodie
um david berger lamar's on my fantasy
team so he's going to he's going for at
least two rushing touchdowns consider
that a lot kelly i know you don't like
that l word
but my guy david berger said consider it
a lock
uh j fry 1414 said let me get a hoodie
greg lamar all day guess what j fry
today's your lucky day you're walking
away with a hoodie cabbie it is very
apparent
it is very apparent the the comments
i've spoken
the christmas tree legend and lamar
jackson
is moving on to the next round hey what
what the audience wants we give them so
uh congrats to uh hunter
parsons fan page you'll make it out of
round one let's get to round two
a few more rounds left here we go our
next pitch comes from
alex moleshko alex who you got
half court backwards shot that means
travis kelsey's going to morgan
yo alex got a mix of of jack harlow and
tyler hero and that
that my the miami vice jersey well done
half court legend
g-money what'd you think of the video
half court legend more like half short
legend my guy's shorts are pretty up
there
but uh that's the style nowadays can you
guys believe it
i mean the kids they rock the shorts up
high now like john's like the 1980s nba
like that's what he's got he's got like
the the short shorts
uh look that was an awesome shot i'll
give him that moment
it's coming back it's coming back full
circle uh
but let's talk about the the pick travis
kelsey sitting at -200
now travis kelsey is a wide receiver
number one cabbie in that in that
kansas city chiefs offense i mean he's
he's he's a beast in that offense i mean
he scored
a touchdown in three straight games uh
he has six
100 plus yard games receiving this year
he's been balling cabbie sitting that
minus 200 uh
i don't i don't i like i like i like the
pick they're facing atlanta it's gonna
be a high scoring game it's going to be
a high
score game the juice the juice is just
uh it kind of throws me off but
i i i like the pick i like him to score
today i just don't know about the juice
but kelly
you know about the juices you know about
the minus 200 plus 120s
you know it all so talk to us travis
kelsey
lamar jackson what would you do who are
you riding with you're right greg i'm
not laying two dollars with travis
kelsey but if draftkings wants to give
me three to one
hello you just said it he's basically a
big body wide receiver look
this is a game i didn't really want to
get involved in
uh atlanta somehow got there for me last
week after blowing a 24-7 lead
i don't know how i got to cash that
ticket but thank you to the gambling
gods that being said
it seems like now everybody's starting
to jump off that kansas city train they
have been a
terrible ats team even though they keep
winning it's those two things usually
it's uh the team that covers wins the
game about 80 percent of the time and
the kansas city chiefs are bucking that
trend
all season long so 11 is a big
number i don't know if i'm gonna get to
the window but the bookmakers over at
draftkings telling me the tickets are
two to one on the dog
this is just odd i do think travis
kelsey does score a touchdown here but
as far as the side goes i'm staying away
kelly you're staying away but let me
tell you the comments they are not
staying
away hey the comments are hilarious
today oh my gosh
the the the the the usernames are funny
i got
i got greg my guy the goat
greg my boy the goat you see my name and
pick we going with lamar
the freak uh lamar jackson they're
rocking with lamar here cabbie
uh shouts out to greg my god the goal
you're welcome with a hoodie i got
another one greg ivory go
there these are literally scream uh
usernames
travis kelsey is a beast he's also on my
fantasy team
so he's going to get in the end zone so
kelsey's walking away with a tv
and a td and i should walk away with a
hoodie greg ivory goat you're walking
away with hoodie cabbie they're back and
forth in the comments i'm going to make
a decision
on the next one i have to make a
decision on the note from the next one
ben the goat kelsey two touchdowns no
cap send a hoodie my way
guess what ben you're walking away with
a hoodie he said kelsey cabbie
he said i said that was gonna go with
the next one i said i was gonna go with
the next one
we're rocking with the half court legend
and travis kelsey moving on nice shot
alex and well done in round two you move
on to round three with
with travis kelsey let's let's get your
next opponent here we go it is from
tanner muller possibly a jamal murray
fan lacrosse bow legend
what's up bleacher report betting this
is how we determine how our squad rides
sunday
down there we got atari with a bunch of
names on i'm gonna get it on target
i'm not gonna like it do it ain't good
it's looking like jalen hurts an anytime
touchdown lock this week
great marksmanship my dude boom right in
the middle of the target
greg ivory what'd you think about the
video
cabbie i'm just happy that i wasn't on
the other side of that fence because i
i didn't know if i can trust my guy you
know with the crossbow
but he did he did he did hit you know
his target so let's let's give him that
and he didn't hit a bad target at that
jalen hurts at plus one 135
that's pretty good value my guy has been
bawling this is
this will be his third start cabbie in
his first two starts he's been balling
he's had some solid production
two career uh he's one and one you know
one and one record
and he scored a russian touchdown last
week against arizona so
sitting at 135 plus 135 it
it's not bad value and you know the
eagles they do love to run
with jalen hurts when he's at
quarterback uh we've seen it last week
uh i think he went over 100 yards or
close to 100 yards last week
uh but kelly talk to me kelly talked to
me we got travis kelsey
jalen hurts plus 135
minus 200 come on kelly talk to us
i i don't have much to say about jalen
hurts i'm happy that he is balling out i
said week four he should have been the
starter maybe i should be the new head
coach of the
legal doug peterson that being said i
have my concerns
with mobile quarterbacks right uh lamar
jackson balls out but now we've started
to see some regression russell wilson mr
unlimited
kind of seems to be uh the one bucking
that narrative
jalen hurts are the cowboys defensive
player is going to be able to stop him
i'm not so sure this defense can't stop
a nosebleed
this is tough i do have the dallas
cowboys in a teaser
i know it's just been teaser teaser
teaser teaser teaser for me the last few
weeks but that's what's been working for
me
i lean towards the cowboys plus three at
home you guys know i love those
divisional dogs
they went 5-0 for us against the spread
last week i'm hoping
we can get another trend like that going
this week
if i got a pick this is tremendous value
on travis kelsey at three to one
so i got to go with kelsey here and uh
the half short legend
kelly i i don't i do not dislike that
jalen hurts actually had 63 rushing
yards last week close to 100 but
you know you know he's up there as for a
quarterback but anyway let me get into
these comments
let me get into these comments hurts is
going to hurt
the cowboys d shouts out to dunk 25
for the gift rocking with you if you
guys can see it yeah there it goes
there there it is yeah you see jalen
hurts all right here we go back into the
comments
here we go uh sloane 58 kelsey how is
this even a question when jesus throws
him the ball he's gonna catch it
i did say hey i did say my guy travis
kelsey was a wide receiver one
and he's always open shout out to chad
johnson sloan 58 you're walking away
with hillary cabby next one
we're just going to ride with it all
right next one we're going to ride with
it
greg is a goon i'm not a goon but anyway
greg is a goon
hertz and lamar rush touchdowns what do
you think
i think that that deserves a hoodie um
you're walking away with the hoodie
cabbie it's a parent my my guy said
hurts
he said hurts jalen hurts okay
moving on to the next round excellent
work tanner
loving the plus 135 all right excellent
work with the marksmanship the crossbow
legend moves on
into the final round this is the the
final matchup
of 2020 on the squad ride so let's get
it i'm excited the final pitch comes
from
the domino legend t doubling it who you
got
all right i heard you're looking for
your lock of the week for anytime td
scorer
and i'm here to give you your lock of
the week harvey hit it
nick chubb well done harvey
and that dude has like every domino who
bought every domino's pack from target i
think uh
over the last couple of weeks thank you
for the video uh g-money what do you
think of the video and the pick nick
chubb
cabbie to be honest i i thought the
video i thought we were going to
take a left turn maybe a right turn
maybe go into a circle you know what i
mean
and then end up on nick chubb possibly
but you know
it was it was a straight line straight
shooter i'm a straight i'm a straight
shooter type of guy straight to the
point
so i get it i get it uh now let's talk
about the pick
nick chubb sitting at minus 167.
i i don't i don't dislike this one uh at
all
cabbie in fact my guy nick chubb is
approaching a thousand yards in 11 games
he's sitting at 9
31 uh maybe he gets to a thousand here
he's been balling and we know that that
browns offense
they need nick chubb in order to get
rolling
um so kelly with that being said talk to
me we got nick chubb sitting at -167
that's not too bad value
uh we got jalen hurt sitting at plus
135.
uh nick chubb is facing that jets
defense
and jalen hurts is facing that dallas
defense
so i'm giving you a little perspective
there talk to me nick chubb
jalen hurts well as you guys know br
gridiron tweeted about several bronze
players not making the trip to new york
well nick chubb did make that trip and i
do think that if the browns
want to win this game yes i do have my
concerns with
the jets being able to not
tank for trevor i don't get what
happened last week but that's beside the
point i guess the jags are going to get
trevor lawrence now
i don't think the jets want to lose and
i think that they're going to come out
and they're going to ball out hard
how are they going to win this game
they've got to put pressure on baker
mayfield and force him to make mistakes
how does that not happen that's right
they give the ball to nick chubb
and that's exactly what they're gonna do
here if they want to win this game
they've got to run the ball
with chubb chubb's gonna put one if not
two
in the end zone excellent uh getting
kelly's calling yeah absolutely
uh get in the comments tell greg what
you think
vote for our winner either nick chubb or
uh
lamar jackson right yes um
no jalen hurts excuse me um kelly
you being able to quietly or loudly
shush your haters on twitter i'm sure it
gives you a nice dopamine hit
it always gives greg and i a nice
dopamine hit whenever we tell your picks
and they come through so shout out again
to the atlanta falcons
um you don't need to win you only need
to cover it's week 16 kelly please give
us
your best bet yeah
cabbie this one's gonna be a little
scary now i apologize i know
we're gonna go with a four win texans
team laying over a touchdown at home
currently seven and a half
at draftkings i think they're a great
teaser option as well
look the bengals what did they do last
week they shocked the world
at home on monday night as a divisional
home
dog now they have to go on the road and
just
keep it close with the texans team look
i don't think this bengals
team so much won that game as the
steelers absolutely handed it to them
this is a chance for the texans to
really start to get things rolling for
next season everything i'm hearing out
of houston is they love romeo cornell
we know that desean watson is going to
be their quarterback
plus we have a pretty solid defense here
that should be able
to keep this one uh from
from them making mistakes i really think
the texans are going to come out they're
going to ball
out i made this game 24-10 so if you
like
the total maybe spring a little bit on
that under as well
and uh let's finish this season strong
gabby indeed yes the texans let's uh
let's end that three-game losing streak
get right versus cincinnati
and let's get rich log on to draftkings
right now get on the app
uh lock in the houston texans g money
greg ivory i know you have your handy
dandy ipad
close by where you have the answer we
are looking for
what is our squad ride in weeks
gabby uh nick chubb i'm i'm just calling
it right now
it's it's a landslide yeah it's
it's it's literally a landslide in the
comments like there's
there's no discussion nick chubb is up
and down i'm gonna give away some
hoodies just because
uh ben the goat nick chubb almost
chubbier than mia
shouts out to him being almost chubbier
than you but you are walking away with
hitting just because it's
it's december uh
d grin uh too much no drown noising i
guess
they're they're going back and back and
forth in the comments bay area guy
87 now that's not deserving of a hoodie
but let me get to some more nick chub
picks
i got ball is life giving me a nick
chubb gift
shouts out to ball is life you're
walking away with a hoodie uh
here we go cabbie last one last one i'm
looking for a good one
here we go salit rashami nick chubb
about to go crazy with no receivers
i'm putting the handy dandy ipad down
because i think it's apparent
can i see the graphic please can i
please see the graphic cause let me show
you guys something that
we and us only on the squad right
the only thing we we only we are we are
the only ones that can do it sorry man i
couldn't get that one out but we are
literally the only ones that can do this
you see nick chubb at -167
change that graphic please change the
graphic
change the graphic please there it is
plus 300
we just changed the from minus one six
167 to plus 300 we only do that here on
the squad ride
make sure you guys tune in to the story
we will be riding with nick chubb to
score a touchdown
today on instagram make sure you guys
tap in send in your videos too get on
the story but
remember y'all say it in the comments
i'm giving away some hoodies
it's one of my favorite moments on the
show also remember to check out br
socials for the link
to the odds boost offered by draftkings
that's br
underscore betting tap in with the homie
greg ivory obviously ig stories are
hella entertaining and one of the best
ways to experience your football
uh sunday thank you to all the
commenters shout out to everybody who
won some hoodies
and um thank you to our legends we have
casey mint
hunter parsons fan page alex molesko
tanner muller and t dublin salute to you
for the nick chubb pick
we are writing so uh alongside kelly
stewart
greg ivory mikey whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa cabbie i told the
people to
i told the people to respond and they're
in the comments responding
our nation winners only please you're
walking away with a hoodie
zev god winners only please you're
walking away with a hoodie
uh here we go uh wmk4
winners only please you're walking away
to hoodie see thomas 16.
winners only please you're walking away
with your money okay we need to we need
some buddies for
for 2021. so let's touch okay let's just
hold on real quick listen thank you
everybody for talking with the squad
squad ride all season we will be back in
the new year
and we will have a refill on hoodies so
grant can give them away
thank you so much for joining the squad
ride good luck everybody
and have a happy and safe new year peace
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you